you know who he is under that Howard
don't you he's my friend that's why you
don't want him dead death would be a
release from this life and his sentence
has yet to be carried out I am going to
tear everything he cares about away from
him destroy those who choose to follow
him corrupt those he loves once he has
lost everyone and everything he values I
will drive an arrow through his eye
Oliver I'd like you to meet mr. Wilson
it's a pleasure to meet you mr. quaint
what are you doing here What's Wrong mr.
Clayton
you look real baked his name is Slade
Wilson and unless we stop him he's gonna
kill Oliver and his entire family
not yet good five years ago I made your
promise well I'm here to fulfill it
Slade Wilson is alive you killed him
it's not possible you know it's okay if
you're scared I am too I'm not scared
so tell me what you are focused this
time I will make damn sure that he stays
dead
I don't know I stopped it you start by
letting people help you
but he's gonna come after you let him
come I'm not that easy to kill there's a
new player we've been tracking we've
been calling him Deathstroke find him
this started with the two of us that's
how it ends
you can't go out there by yourself it's
suicide they're designated Task Force X
welcome to The Suicide Squad Oh Jay
Charles Manson one available
Big Shot is a girl that smells a gal I
used to go
I created the Huntress yeah we you
create slate too
allies just as you have yours
be prepared for anything
if they're wearing a mask to get a
bullet
once you let the darkness inside it
never comes out
are you gonna do kill me hey youtubers
it's Charlie and Stephen Amell just
posted a new trailer for the back half
of arrow season 2 that's right there's
actually a bunch of episodes that they
cover in this clip he was kind of being
funny when he called it arrow the movie
because he did say in a Q&A previously
that he was totally open to doing an
arrow movie after the series was over
which isn't gonna be for a long time I
expect the series to run at least five
seasons obviously Deathstroke is the
connective tissue across all the
episodes this season but we see stuff
from the Suicide Squad episode as well
as the birds of prey episode if you
never read it villains United was
actually a run of comic books that
included Suicide Squad and a bunch of
other events during the Infinite Crisis
event that DC did during 2006 to 2007
it's really cool but it's just another
way to describe how there are a lot of
villain arts the last half of this
season between brother blood the actual
Deathstroke arc Suicide Squad and the
birds of prey if you haven't seen it
I've already talked a lot about the
birds of prey episode in my previous Q&A
is Suicide Squad is obviously going to
be them going after Deathstroke the
interesting part of that is this going
to be a Diggle centric episode just like
the Russia field trip episode in the
first half of the season I don't think
that means that Oliver is going to hook
up with Summer Glau like he did the last
time though I don't think the canary
would like that too much so the way the
trailer was edited jumped around a time
a lot so for instance that clip of Roy
punching Slade which was totally awesome
actually comes in the next episode but
the birds of prey comes after Suicide
Squad so it kind of jumped around a
little bit the thing that I'm most
looking forward to is the convergence of
all these superheroes and villains for
the season finale it's gonna be really
interesting to see how Oliver solves the
solution of Slade obviously we have to
have several amazing action sequences
first but what I'm really thinking is is
that it's going to turn into a
Redemption arc for Slade yes Deathstroke
is a villain in the comic books but I
think that Oliver is going to try and
redeem him at some point it'll be really
interesting to see how season 3
continues that arc because I expect that
slave will be back at least in some form
I don't think he'll be the main villain
I think there'll be someone else that'll
come the other really interesting thing
about this is now
they've introduced the Suicide Squad
they can totally bring them back next
season too as well as the birds of prey
so now it's your turn let me know in the
comments what was your favorite moment
from the trailer I'm kind of thinking
that it was Deathstroke putting on the
mask in the full-on shop we haven't
really gotten a well-lit shot of him in
the costume yet really just close-ups
and quick moves past the camera so new
episode of arrow tomorrow night it's the
promise it will be amazing be sure to
subscribe to get my video I've also
spent most of this season talking about
the rest of the arts this season so you
can click here to get all my other arrow
videos to find out what's going on
and you can click here to get my trailer
for transformers for that just posted
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives
you